welcome back America to the conversation
about your life and your money it is the
Dave Ramsey show we're so thrilled to
have you with us
rachel cruz and chris hogan taking your
questions it is a free call triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you can also engage us on Facebook and
Twitter the Twitter handle for the
ramsey show Dave ranch show is at Ramsey
show and you can find us at facebook.com
slash Dave Ramsey
up next is Armando in Chicago Armando
you're on the Dave Ramsey show how can
we help hey guys how's it going good how
are you very good
so I have a two-part question um so I'll
start off by saying that I would like to
start saving for retirement arm here are
some of the facts I'm currently single
I'm 29 years old I make an annual salary
of 66 thousand um my baby step one is
done as far as that is concerned and I
am on the debt snowball plan so I have
eight thousand dollars in credit card
debt and ten thousand dollars in student
loan debt
um I plan on paying off all my credit
card debt by the end of this year and
I'm gonna work aggressively towards
paying my student loans next year um
should I delay retirement investing if
it takes a year or slightly over a year
to clear up all my debts and then I
guess before you guys answer that is I
want to start computing 15%
um towards retirement every you know
every paycheck um but I don't want to
get into the habit of pressing pause for
life events so I know that I'm probably
going to be asking my girlfriend for
engagement since I'm at the sacrum for
an engagement ring and then looking
long-term like a down payment for a
house um do do people traditionally
pause retirement to save up for those
things or do you kind of just
incorporate it into your budget yeah
these are all great questions and the
fact that you're 29 years old gives me
hope for our generation Armando I'll
tell you that much yeah so I would say
for paying off the debt absolutely don't
fund retirement quite yet and so for all
math people out there they're probably
cringing and freaking out right now
because I go no the Matt she's going to
lose the match for two years listen for
a short period of time
focus all of your money on paying off
that debt an 18-grand
Armando you could kill that I mean you
could sacrifice so much of your
lifestyle and pay that off even faster
than two years and so I would say focus
all of your intensity on that and then
start looking into the future and again
if you want to take even a year off of
retirement even delay it even one more
year to start paying saving for that
engagement ring which congratulations
that that's going so well so glad you're
happy for you and then also for that
down payment we say we follow the baby
steps which I know you just said that
which is so true so baby step one $2,000
maybe set two is paying off all of your
debt but your house baby step three is
three to six months of expenses in the
bank and so those are things you want to
cover first before getting to baby step
four which is funding retirement yeah
absolutely I want to say congratulations
on being focused you are intentional and
I like that my friend I'm serious uh
people like you you're going to win
because you're zeroed in now whenever
you're staring at to larger kind of
dollar amount things with the engagement
ring and then the house down payment I
would tell you this with a home down
payment you want to look at that as baby
step three be alright and that's after
you all are getting married and
obviously you're together saving toward
that down payment on a home being in
Chicago you know it's all about location
and where you buy so I would tell you
this it is not against the law for you
to get married and you all go rent
somewhere while you continue to save up
I want a lot of people to hear me there
the other side of it with the engagement
ring is be reasonable okay this is one
of those things as you look at this and
you're saving up for it if I'm you right
now what I would do is try to figure out
is there a second job I could take on to
allow me to kind of gain traction and
attack the credit card debt and then get
the student loan debt out of your life
because when you look at how much you're
paying on the eight thousand and credit
card debt in the ten thousand and
student loan that would be a heck of a
jump start to you saving to these other
things so I love that I mean this is a
young man that's intentional yes and at
29 it's okay for him to again stay
focused on the debt people stay focused
at tacket attack it and then you can
start to do other things because the
power of being debt-free is it's lowered
your risk when you don't know anyone
anything it's amazing and then being
able to kind of snowball and jump onto
that
Tyrel even more yes but how encouraging
it is that you know here in a few years
around that you're going to start doing
that and you're going to see those
numbers that compound interests work in
your favor because you are starting
young and I'd also tell Armando to make
sure his fiancee right she's been
plugged into Financial Peace University
yeah like we need to know on the same
page and for she rings out there does
she know and what does she have that's
right and so for young couples out there
or not so young couples to have that
conversation just so we can be upfront
and know where are we starting off I
would put cash on the table that Armando
has had that conversation it seems a
pair he says it before you answer the
question yes few more positions I don't
think that we need you yeah later
I bet home is girlfriend but engagement
rings people go crazy with this everyone
needs to know even late ladies up there
I'm talking to you oh that just because
you get one ring doesn't mean that you
can't upgrade later in life meaning
saving you know spending one month
salary on something on that is good and
if you're like oh no but my but no but
my fiance doesn't have a great paying
job hey it's okay listen don't like put
on your side I talked to some girls that
they expect a certain level ring on my
own girlfriend get off that high horse
get a great ring your husband or your
fiance's can get you a great ring and
then later in life you can upgrade your
technique so that you're betting
credulous Chris okay well I just I don't
like how she threw out the word upgrade
it's just male trying to buy the first
ring tried to save treating the money
and I'm like no I just feel like
economically you're tying up armando's
money okay you're trying to get him to
upgrade ring listen to me how do you
upgrade into the initial early
conversations really really first ring
doesn't have to be crazy that's true
that's fine okay but don't mention
upgrade is what we're saying yeah no but
she's right you can't upgrade later when
after the kids are out of the home and
you've got a few years later and you've
got a lot of money in retirement
Chris Hogan is spoken hey you guys
Rachel Chris here hope you're enjoying
the Dave Ramsey show
and did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better than the Dave Ramsey channel
don't tell them I said that I'm kidding
I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you